SHAQ: People always say,
"What do you want
your legacy to be?"
I wanna be known as
one of the greats.
ANNOUNCER:
Meet Shaquille O'Neal.
SHAQ: What's up, baby?
My momma always used to say...
Something special
about that one.
SHAQ: Take you back.
Thirteen years old, 6'9.
There was a guy who says,
"You're 6'9 and you can't dunk."
I gave him the beatdown
of his life.
At that point, I was dreaming
about being a rapper.
I was dreaming about
being a basketball player.
I was just dreaming about
being rich.
LUCILLE O'NEAL: I think
what carries him is the support
that he always got from family.
SHAQ: My father always told me,
"I'm gonna make you better
than I was."
I love you, boy!
My dad would always tell us,
"Y'all might hate my ways..."
"But you love my results."
SHAQ: His words.
"If you listen to me,
I'll make you one of the best
basketball players ever."
♪ (INTENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
When I won the championship,
my father says,
"You know how we roll, brother.
Go get another one."
Yes, sir.
SPEAKER: When he wants to
take over a game,
with his strength
and athleticism,
there's nothing you can do.
Shaq is legitimately
one of the best centers
that the NBA had ever seen.
He was like 373 pounds.
He's a big guy.
SHAQ: Because of my size,
they had to get super physical.
But my superpower
is getting mad.
When I get mad, it's over.
♪ Show you no mercy
Yeah, show me respect ♪
SPEAKER 2: He was so dominant,
so quick,
but he was playful
and full of love.
♪ Who going harder than me? ♪
You know, until he's not.
SHAQ:
When people start talking...
Those are words that
I'll punch you in your face for.
SPEAKER 3:
When you're at the top,
little chinks in your armor
that are underneath,
everybody gets to look up
at those for longer.
SHAQ: I was under
the most pressure.
I'm still dealing with it.
♪ Who got the heart
Of the king? ♪
I like making people laugh.
My mission in life now is to
just brighten up peoples' day.
SPEAKER 4:
He chooses to just be fun.
Let Shaquille be Shaquille,
and the magic will come.
Stop.
Just shoot the money, brother.
I always take advantage
of opportunities.
I want to make so much money
on the side.
DWAYNE WADE:
His message to me was,
"Whatever you're gonna do,
it's your brand,
so make sure it's your voice."
Black Friedrich Nietzsche
over here.
I really am the man.
He presented an example
of how to brand yourself
beyond the game.
You can't open your eyes
and not see him.
When a father's quizzing his son
on great, big men of the game...
hopefully Shaquille O'Neal's
name will be in the answer.
♪ Who going harder than me? ♪
♪ Nobody ♪